Hello listener, this is Jason Bateman along with Will Arnett and Sean Hayes for the podcast called Smartless. If that's a place you're looking for, you've found it. Congratulations. It's not a real high concept podcast. One person invites a guest, the other two don't know who that guest is and then we chat. Here we go. I have a quick question to the side of Will as a window where I see workers just constantly not giving up. Really a lot of decoration going into Denny's room. Yeah. What are they doing over there? Are they building a room for your awards that you hope to get one day? Yeah. Well, I just said, I said, look, I'm doing this podcast and this thing's about to clean up. So I'm going to need a
听众朋友们大家好，我是杰森·贝特曼，和威尔·阿奈特以及肖恩·海耶斯一起主持这档名为《Smartless》的播客。如果你是在找这个节目，那你就找对地方了。恭喜你。这并不是一个概念很深奥的播客。一个人邀请一位嘉宾，另外两个人不知道嘉宾是谁，然后我们就开始聊天。开始了。我有个小问题，威尔旁边有个窗户，我看到工人们一直在忙活，从没停过。丹尼的房间里真的放了很多装饰品。是啊。他们在那里做什么？他们是在为你希望有一天能拿到的奖项建一个陈列室吗？是啊。嗯，我刚才说了，我说，听着，我正在做这个播客，这节目马上就要大获成功了。所以我需要建一个神龛。所以现在还不是真正的神龛。显然这只是神龛的底座。他们在建什么？不，他们在建婴儿房，给新宝宝准备的。我们正在翻新以前的客房，现在成了小丹尼的房间。哦，那真不错。你以前在那间房里招待过客人吗？丹，你明白吗？杰森，我确实在那间房里招待过几位客人。真的吗？是啊。天哪，你问这个问题的方式真够烂的。告诉我都有谁？我父母有一次住过，我再也没犯过那种错。他们正在听呢。我父母才不会听。他们不听我的节目。或者他们认识的人可能会听到，然后发给他们。更有可能。虽然我经常这么做。我经常在吉米·坎摩尔的节目上拿我父母开涮，我总是开玩笑说他们永远不会听到。然后我妈就会给我发短信说，你在吉米节目上说的话完全不是真的。我就想，天哪。不，那只是个段子。我总是试图在脱口秀节目上把我的妻子推出去当挡箭牌，但她很早就制止了这种行为。之后我就没招了。我真的没招了。我经常拿斯科蒂开涮。每次都管用。总是管用。我最喜欢的靶子是杰森。我承受了很多炮火。
shrine built. So it's not an actual shrine yet. Obviously it's just the base of a shrine. What are they building? No, they're building, this is the baby's room, the new baby. We're renovating what used to be the guest room is now little Denny's room. Oh, that's nice. Did you ever have a guest in that room? Den, do you get it? I have had a couple of guests in that room, Jason. Really? Yeah. Boy, the way you asked that was so shitty. Tell me who? My parents once, I never made that mistake again. They're listening. My parents are not listening. They don't
他承受了很多炮火。我觉得我是第二个。我很想知道第三个是谁。听着，肖恩，如果你想让我多拿你开涮，你只需要开口就行。你在干什么？天哪。这让我想到了我们今天的嘉宾，一位非常特别的嘉宾。此人在其领域取得了令人难以置信的卓越成就。此人打进了656个进球。参加了超过1500场NHL比赛。他作为球员赢得了三次斯坦利杯冠军，作为球员获得过一枚奥运金牌，一枚世锦赛金牌。他是所谓的“三金俱乐部”精英群体中的一员。我当时就在
listen to me. Or somebody they know may hear this and then send it to them. More likely. Although I do that all the time. I take shots of my parents as a bit all the time on Kimmel and I'm always joking that they'll never hear it. And then my mom will send me a text like, that is absolutely not true what you said on Jimmy. And I'm like, oh my gosh. No, it's a bit. I always try to throw my wife under the bus for bits on talk shows and she put the kibosh on that early on. And I got nothing. After that I got nothing. I constantly use Scotty. It all works every time. It always works. My favorite target is Jason. I take a lot of fire.
颁奖典礼上和他在一起。他在职业生涯结束后，在辉煌的职业生涯之后，在NHL选秀中以第二顺位被选中，在经历了名人堂级别的职业生涯后——我当时因为那个周末很忙没能参加颁奖典礼，我想他可能从来没原谅过我。在那之后还有关于发型的奖项。他有一头令人难以置信的秀发。他曾为NHL的球员安全部门工作，那以前算是规则执行部门，他把名字改成了球员安全部门，因为他非常注重良好的公关。他是个很棒的人。顺便说一句，听起来我们根本不需要和他说话，因为你只是……他现在是NHL的总裁，他是总裁兼
He takes a lot of fire. I feel like I'm the second. I'd love to know what the third one is. Listen, Sean, if you want me to take more shots at you, all you've got to do is ask. What are you doing? Holy crap. That brings me to our guest today, a very special guest. This person has excelled in their field beyond belief. This person has scored 656 goals. Over 1,500 NHL games. He has won three Stanley Cup championships as a player, one Olympic gold medal as a player, one gold medal in the world championship. He's one of an elite group of people who were in the triple gold club, they call it. I was actually at the
NHL的候补理事，也是多伦多枫叶队的总裁。是这样吗？女士们先生们，布兰登·沙纳汉先生。让他进来吧。他就在那儿。你好啊。干眼症。给他擦干眼泪，沙纳汉。
ceremony with this guy. He then took his career after his playing career and after an illustrious career drafted number two in the NHL draft after this hall of fame career, which I couldn't make the ceremony because I was busy that weekend and I don't think he's ever forgiven me. And then after that awards for the hair. He has got incredible hair. He worked for the NHL and the player safety department, which used to be the sort of rules enforcement and he changed the name to player safety because he's all about good PR. He's a great guy. By the way, it sounds like we don't have to talk to him because you're just, he is now the president of, he's the president and an
让我直接切入正题，问第一个问题。你和威尔到底是怎么认识的？为什么是你和威尔·阿奈特？那是怎么发生的？顺便说一句，沙纳汉，你可以随意讲真实的故事或者编造的故事。嗯，我先讲编造的故事吧。我不记得我们是不是……我想我们当时是在健身房锻炼，故事总是这样开始的。总是这样开始的，总是这样开始的。我也是。那是我们的编造故事。那是我们的编造故事。酒吧斗殴。真实的故事是我在巴尼斯百货的五楼看毛衣，突然威尔·阿奈特走了过来
alternate governor for the NHL and president of the Toronto Maple Leafs. Is that right? Ladies and gentlemen, Mr. Brendan Shanahan. Let him go. There he is. Hello there. Dry eye. Dry him up Shanahan.
对我说，嘿，伙计。嘿，伙计。我认识一些你也认识的人。哦，天哪。是啊，这是我的招牌搭讪语。其实，你知道，威尔，我想你比我小一两岁，但我们确实在同一个社区长大，我们有一些一起上高中的朋友，所以我想你可以帮我提一下，是的，当时我真的不知道这会引出后来的一切。否则我可能早就走开了。
Let me dive right in and ask the first question. How in the world did you and will meet? Why are you and will are next? When did that happen? By the way, Shanahan, feel free to tell the real or a fake story. Well, I'll, I'll tell the fake story first. I forget if we, I think we were at a gym working out and that's how it always starts. Always starts always starts like that. Me too. That's our fake story. That's our fake story. Barroom brawl. The true story is I was on the fifth floor of Barney's looking at sweaters and all of a sudden will our net walked up
但下一步是更衣室吗？我是说，他是不是那种说，“嗯，让我看看你穿上那件衣服的样子。”我是说，你想要新鲜的眼光，对吧？你想要新鲜的眼光。让我帮你把那个配色组合在一起，然后他挑了一些裤子，我觉得那很可爱。就是这样。嗯，我觉得我们还是坚持那个编造的故事吧。巴尼斯百货，顺便说一句，现在
to me and it's like, Hey man. Hey man. I know some people you know. Oh boy. Yeah. And it's my go to pick up line. It was actually, you know, will and I, I think will you're a year or two younger than me, but we did grow up in the same neighborhood and we had some friends that we went to high school with and so I think you can help and mention that and yeah, and I didn't really know at the time that it would lead to all of this. Otherwise I probably would have walked
我们已经暴露年龄了。现在的孩子们会说，巴尼斯百货？那是什么？那甚至都不存在了。我知道。你们得在网上认识。非常复古。你们得像在Mr. Porter上认识人一样。是啊。顺便说一句，说到我们什么时候认识的，其实，对不起，威尔，但杰森和我认识的时间比你和我认识的时间还要早得多。
away. But was the next step the changing rooms? I mean, was he like saying, Well, let me see that on you. And I'll, I mean, you want fresh eyes, right? You want fresh eyes. Let me help you put that color combo together and he picked out some pants and I think that's cute. That's it. Well, I think we stick with the fake story. Barney's, and by the way, now
那是真的。没错。等不及要听我们的故事了。洛根一家。不是吗？是通过乔什·泰勒。肖恩，这是我们的故事。
and now we're dating ourselves. Like the kids now are going to go Barney's. What's a Barney's? And it doesn't even exist. I know. You'd have to meet online. Very vintage. You'd meet it like Mr. Porter meeting guys online. Yeah. By the way, speaking of when we met actually, I'm sorry, Will, but Jason and I go even
你和我今天。就是这样。希望30年后，我们还会重述这个故事。是啊。留着你的电脑。是啊。他叫什么名字来着？杰森？
way further back than you and I. That's true. That's right. Can't wait for our story. The Logan family. Wasn't it? It was through Josh Taylor. Sean, this is our story.
不是乔什·泰勒吗？那个在剧中扮演我爸爸的人。他和你或者肖恩·伯克或者魔鬼队的某个人是哥们，对吧？我们……夏天我在安大略省布兰特福德参加韦恩·格雷茨基的慈善活动。我刚结束新秀赛季，我刚满19岁，我在这个活动上坐在他旁边，在晚餐坐在他旁边度过一个晚上后，他说，你知道，你和我在剧里的那个孩子年纪一样大。我得介绍你们认识，你什么时候去洛杉矶比赛？
You and I today. This is it. Hopefully in 30 years, we're going to be retelling this one. Yeah. Keep your, keep your computer. Yeah. Well, what was his name? Jason?
我说明年。所以我给了他我的号码，不知怎么的，我们当时都是……在那段时间。花了我几年时间才明白。所以他当时是想撮合我们。原来是这样。布兰登，这确实是我们的第一个故事，这会很自然地引出后续。所以是的，你们来了，你们和国王队比赛，乔什和我去看了那场比赛，然后我们之后一起出去吃了冰淇淋。
Wasn't it Josh Taylor? The guy who played my dad on the show. He was buddies with you or with Sean Burke or with somebody with the devils, right? We, I was at a charity thing for Wayne Gretzky in Branford, Ontario in the summertime. I just finished my rookie year, I was, I had just turned 19 and I sat beside him at this event and after, after an evening, having dinner next to him, he said, you know, you're the same age as this kid on my show. I got to introduce you when, when are you playing in LA?
是啊。没关系。我们当时多大，19岁？我想我在那天晚上结束时救了你的命。是啊。然后我有点……你不会相信的，威尔。我想我当时有点口无遮拦，是和肖恩·伯克吗？是啊。
I said next year. So I gave him my number and somehow we were both gay at that time. It took me a couple of years to get it. So he was trying to set us up. That's what that was. And Brandon, this really is our first story, this will just parlay so easily. So yeah, you guys came out, you guys played the Kings and Josh and I went to that game and then we all went out afterwards and got ice cream.
还是我去找其中一个暴徒了？谁是那个执行者？丹尼卡想杀了你。伯克想杀了你。丹尼卡。肯尼·丹尼卡想杀了贝特曼。等等，我当时只是讨厌，还是我想取笑别人？两者都有。
Yeah. That's all right. What were we, 19 years old at the time and I think I saved your life at the end of the night. Yeah. And then I got a little, you're not going to believe this, Will. I think I was running my mouth a bit with, was it with Sean Burke? Yeah.
嗯，我想两者都有。是啊。因为那种情况下没有“或者”。嗯，你还记得其中的一些吗？因为我肯定什么都不记得了，但我当时是什么样？我是不是在说，我还能闻到你制服的味道，或者我在谈论攻击加拿大？你当时是什么……你其实是那个邀请他们所有人打架的人，你告诉他们，你看起来可能不强硬，
Or did I go after one of the thugs? Who was the enforcer? Danica wanted to kill you. Burke wanted to kill you. Danica. Kenny Danica wanted to kill Bateman. Wait, was I just obnoxious or was I trying to like make fun of people? Both.
但你其实很强硬，然后你要把他们都揍一顿。顺便说一句，他现在还是用这招开场。你能相信我戒酒了吗？你为什么不戒？他们对我说，他们说，嘿，沙尼，你带来的这个哥们是谁？我想我们当时是在机场万豪酒店的房间里闲逛。那是他的地盘。
Well, I guess that's both. Yeah. Because there's no or in that sense. Well, can you remember any of the, because I certainly can't remember anything, but like, what was I like, did I, was I saying I can smell, I can still smell your uniform or was I talking about taking shots at Canada? What was I, what was, you, you actually were the one that was, that was inviting a fist fight with all of them and you were telling them that, that you might not look tough,
那是贝特曼的地盘。机场万豪酒店。就像快速撤离，你知道，以防万一情况变糟，我可以马上离开。你当时多大，杰森？他们当时19岁，对吧？你们当时19岁？是啊。是啊。
but that you were, and then you were going to kick all their asses. By the way, he still opens with that. Can you believe that I stopped drinking? Why didn't you stop? And they're saying to me, they're saying like, Shani, like who's this buddy of yours you brought to this? I think we're at like the airport Marriott just hanging out in a room. That was his spot.
所以这很有趣。令人震惊的是，那是最后一次我见到杰森，然后21年后，现在和威尔成了哥们，我仍然令人震惊地在NHL打球，我40岁了，我为新泽西魔鬼队效力，威尔带杰森来看了一场比赛，我们之后出去重聚了。我们说，这一定是两名球员在冰球比赛后聚在一起时间跨度最长的世界纪录。一定是，这很奇怪，这也奇怪，因为你开始NHL职业生涯时
That was Bateman's spot. The airport Marriott. Like make quick outs, you know, just in case something gets hot, I can just leave. How old were you, Jason? They were 19, right? You guys are 19 at the time? Yeah. Yeah.
为魔鬼队效力，然后你在魔鬼队结束，那仍然是为同一支球队效力时间跨度最长的，比如被交易，你知道，离开然后去别的地方签约，然后再回来。是啊。这真的不是你想拥有的纪录，它只是说明你老了。就像，我想这是为同一支球队进球时间跨度最长的纪录。大概有20年左右，这只是一个不太礼貌的邀请，请你退役。
And so it's funny. That was shockingly, that was the last night I ever saw Jason and then 21 years later now buddies with Will and I'm still shockingly playing in the NHL, I'm 40 and I'm playing for the New Jersey Devils and Will brought Jason to a game and we went out afterwards and reconnected. We said it was, had to be a world record for the biggest gap between two guys hanging out together after a hockey game. It's got to be, which is weird, which is also weird because you started your NHL career
因为他们在轮椅底部装了冰刀，对吧？是啊。当然。那第二轮。现在，沙尼，你……我不想现在变得严肃，但你是否像我想象的那样，因为你获得了一个真正利用了你所吸收、学习、欣赏和尊重的一切的职位而感到激动？
playing for the Devils and then you ended with the Devils and that was, that is still the longest gap between playing for the same team, like being traded, you know, leaving and going, signing somewhere else and coming back. Yeah. It's, it's not really a record you want to have, it just says you're old. It's like, I think it's like the longest gap between scoring goals for the same team. It was like 20 years or something, it was just an invitation, not so polite invitation to please retire.
因为很多人，你知道，他们可能只是在做一件事时达到极限，却从来没有机会多元化发展，去利用他们所学到的一切。我是说，我想这一定是一种很有成就感的感觉。哇。全力以赴。是啊。那很好。
Because they put skates on the bottom of the wheelchair, right? Yeah. Of course. That second round. Now, Shani, are you, are you, I don't want to get serious now, but are you as thrilled as I would imagine you are that you have earned a position that actually takes advantage of everything that you have absorbed and learned and appreciated and respected about your, your field?
你知道吗，这其实是一个很好的观点。我很幸运。但是你知道，这可能和你们做的事情没什么不同。当你转型到工作的其他部分，比如播客，播客这个。是的。是的。不，但我会这么说，在我职业生涯的后期，有一年
Because a lot of people, you know, they might just kind of max out doing one thing and never really get a chance to diversify into something that takes full advantage of everything that they've learned. I mean, I imagine it's got to be kind of a rewarding feeling. Whoa. Full swing. Yeah. That's good.
联盟发生了劳资纠纷，我想我当时35或36岁。所以我当时确实是在结束我的职业生涯。在那之前，我一直认为我停止打球的那一天就是你们最后一次在冰球场见到我的日子。就像我一生都在这里度过。就是这样。我迫不及待地想摆脱这种压力。我迫不及待地想尝试一些新的东西。
You know what, it's actually, it's, it's, it's a great point. I am lucky. It was, but you know, I, it's probably not a lot different than what you guys do. And, and when you transitioned to other, you know, parts of your job and podcasting, podcast this. Yes. Yes. No, but it's, I'll say this, like late, late in my career, there was a, there was a year
所以当时有一个为期一年的停摆，2004年或2005年的实际冰球赛季被取消了。这对我来说是一次大开眼界的经历，让我意识到我其实真的很热爱这项运动，我热爱这项运动的许多方面。而且，它教会了我，在我职业生涯即将结束时，我还有大约三四年的职业生涯，我当然不需要退下来去参加脱口秀、和哥们打高尔夫球、讲老故事的巡回活动。我只是想开始工作，找到一个早上起床的理由，
where there's a labor dispute with the league and I was, I believe I was 35 or 36. So I was really sort of winding down my career. And up until then I had always thought the day I am done playing is the last day you will see me inside a hockey rink. Like I've spent my whole life here. That's it. I can't wait to not have this pressure on me. I can't wait to, to try something new.
并保持动力。所以，这真的很有帮助。所以是的，不，我在多伦多长大，我总是对我的朋友说，因为我在纽约住了很长时间，在我为游骑兵队效力之后，你知道，我作为枫叶队的总裁，就像一个在布朗克斯长大的孩子成为纽约洋基队的总裁一样。这对我来说是一个巨大的刺激。是啊。
And so there was a year long lockout where the actual hockey season in 2004 or 2005 was canceled. And it was, it, it was like a great eye opening experience for me to realize that I actually really loved the game and I loved many aspects of the game. And, and it, it taught me as I was winding down my career, I had about three or four years left in my career that, that I would certainly, I didn't need to step away and do the talk show golfing with your buddies, telling old stories, uh, circuit. And I just wanted to get to work and, and find a reason to get up in the morning and
是啊。对我们来说。对我们来说。没错。所以当我第一次接受枫叶队的工作面试时，我已经退役五年了，我一直在国家冰球联盟的球员安全部门工作。所以他们给我打了电话，你知道，多伦多的媒体，如此以冰球为中心，保持私密性非常重要，我们保持了……某种程度上……远离
be motivated. And so, uh, that was really helpful. And, uh, so yeah, no, I grew up here in Toronto and I always, I always say to my friends, because I lived in New York for a long time when, after I played for the Rangers, you know, me being the president of the Maple Leafs is like a kid that grew up in the Bronx being president of the New York Yankees. It's, it's just a huge thrill for me. Yeah.
媒体。所以没人知道。然后我接受了这份工作，只是对CEO说了，我回到家告诉了我的妻子和孩子们，她说，嗯，我说，看，还没人知道，但我已经接受了这份工作。我们已经商定了条款，我要去为多伦多枫叶队工作。她说，好吧，谁，你必须告诉某人。我说，我要告诉对我意义最重大的两个人，我要打电话给
Yeah. For us. For us. That's right. So when I first got interviewed for the job for the Maple Leafs, I had, I'd been retired for five years and I'd been working at the National Hockey League in player safety. And, uh, so they called me and, and, you know, with the media here in Toronto, so hockey-centric, it was really important that we kept it private and we kept it, uh, sort of, uh, out of the
我妈妈，我要打电话给威尔·阿奈特。你在告诉妈妈之前告诉了我，我想你当时担心她会告诉邻居。你可能是对的。我想我给威尔发了短信，上面只写着，嘿伙计，我刚刚被任命为多伦多枫叶队的总裁，他给我回了短信。我们做到了。威尔，你甚至知道他在面试这份工作吗？
media. So no one knew. And then I, I accepted the job, uh, just to the CEO and I came home and I told my wife and my kids and she said, um, I said, look, no one knows yet, uh, but, but I've accepted the job. We've agreed the terms and, and I'm going to go work for the Toronto Maple Leafs. And she said, well, who, you have to tell someone. I said, I'm going to tell the two people it means the most to, uh, I'm going to call
不，我不认为，也许，不，我不认为我知道。我不会信任他的。我不会信任他的。不，我想我不知道。在我心里，我知道。在我心里，我们……我们为此费尽心思。你在会议上。嗯，沙尼和我跟凯瑟琳谈过这件事，你知道，作为一个家庭，我们都谈过
my mom and I'm going to call Will Arnett. You told me before you told your mom, you were worried that she was going to tell the neighbors, I think. You might be right. I think I texted Will and it's just said like, Hey man, I'm, uh, I've just been named the president of the Toronto Maple Leafs and he texted me back. We did it. Well, did you even know that he was, that he was, uh, meeting on the job?
这件事。嗯，不，我没有，但这太重要了。这太棒了，因为我当时想，终于我可以把我的意志强加给多伦多枫叶队了。你还有另一个严肃的问题吗？不。嗯，我是说，拜托。你是……你有……你有“耳语权力”，对吧？
No, I don't think, maybe, no, I don't think I did. I wouldn't have trusted him. I wouldn't have trusted him. No, I guess I didn't. In my mind, I did. In my mind, we, we, we labored over it. You're at the meeting. Well, Shannie and I talked to Catherine about it, you know, we, as a family, we all talked
所以你不是……你不是在做……具体的员工决定，但你确实有影响力，因为你可以对沙尼说，嘿，伙计，你看到那个新秀了吗？我只是觉得他很棒。你知道，这可能是非常被动的，开玩笑，撇开玩笑不谈，确实有几次，在刚入职不久的时候，有一个非常有趣的时刻。
about it. Um, but no, I, I didn't, but it was huge. It was so great cause I was like, finally I can impose my will on the Toronto Maple Leafs. And have you another serious question? No. Well, but I mean, come on. You are, you, you have, you have whisper power, right?
沙尼，你记得你在看不同的球员，你正在开始这个重建。肖恩，你必须明白多伦多枫叶队在多伦多就是一切。这就是全部。多年来，球队一直处于混乱状态，我们这么说吧，只是为了……沙尼真的重建了，他们实际上称之为“沙纳计划”，这……哦天哪，我知道，对吧？而你现在看到的，我真的在看。
So you're not, you're not, you're not making, you know, uh, uh, tangible personnel decisions, but you do have influence because you could say to Shannie, Hey, boy, did you see that rookie? I just think that he is great. You know, it could be very passive joking, all joking aside, there have, you know, of course I don't in any real way and that's not the way it works. But there have been a couple of times there was a really funny time not long into the job.
这是四、五年前的事了，对吧？五年前。好的。因为我刚开始看迈克尔·乔丹的纪录片，我在你说话的时候，把它和公牛队在乔丹和罗德曼出现之前处于烂摊子的情况进行了比较。我们得到了……这会引起很大争议。我迫不及待地想听人们说他们怎么敢这么说，但我们得到了我们的迈克尔·乔丹，
Shannie, you remember that you were looking at different players and you were starting this rebuild. Sean, for, you have to understand the Toronto Maple Leafs in Toronto are it. It's the, it's all there is. And for years, the team had been. In disarray, let's say, just to be, and Shannie really rebuilt the, they actually called it the Shanna plan, which, uh, oh boy, I know, right? And what you now see now truly I'm watching.
奥斯汀·马修斯，然后是米奇·马纳什么的。这些是沙尼一直在拼凑的碎片，但你必须明白。所以他们真的在努力，他在努力弄清楚，但我记得有一天晚上我坐在家里，我在看，我就想，你知道枫叶队应该得到谁吗？他们应该买断当时还在国王队的迈克·理查兹，他赢过奥运金牌，赢过斯坦利杯，是个来自安大略省卡诺拉的勤奋孩子。我就想，他们应该得到迈克·理查兹，我去找沙尼说，你应该考虑一下
This is like four, five years, right? Five years ago. Okay. Cause I'm just started watching the Michael Jordan documentary and I'm, I'm, I'm kind of as you're talking, comparing it to how the bulls were in the shithole, the Chicago Bulls until Jordan and that whole and Rodman became along. And we got our, this is going to be so controversial. I can't wait for people to say how dare they say it, but we got our Michael Jordan with
买断迈克·理查兹，他给我发了一个截图，你还记得吗？他给我发了一个截图，你当时的笔记本电脑正开着，你一直在看迈克·理查兹的数据。不，他最终没这么做，但是的，我们只是心有灵犀，我们只是接对方的话茬。这太棒了。太棒了。
Austin Matthews and, and then, and then Mitch Marner or whatever. These are the pieces that, that Shannie's been putting together, but you have to understand. So they were really trying to, he was trying to figure it out, but I remember one night I was sitting at home and I was watching and I was like, you know, who the Leafs ought to get? They ought to buy out here at the time he was still with the Kings, Mike Richards, who had won Olympic gold, won Stanley copies, a hardworking kid from a Kanora, Ontario. And I was like, they ought to get Mike Richards and I take Shannie go, you ought to think about
是啊。但沙尼，所以肖恩，我要给你一点关于布兰登的很酷的事情的背景，我们叫他沙尼，但你必须问的是，他在1987年选秀中以第二顺位被选中。对。他从青年队出来时备受推崇，第二顺位，他被新泽西魔鬼队选中。当时的总经理是这位名叫卢·拉莫雷洛的绅士，他拥有
buying out Mike Richards and he sent me a screen, do you remember this? He sent me a screenshot of your laptop was up at that moment and you had been looking at Mike Richards stats. No, he didn't end up doing it, but yeah, we're just connected, we just finished each other sentences. It just is. Awesome. Awesome.
辉煌的NHL总经理生涯。他赢得了多个斯坦利杯。他后来还创办了那家伟大的运动装公司，瑜伽裤和卢·拉曼。是啊。我想没多少人知道这一点。没人知道。对不起。请继续。
Yeah. But Shannie, so Sean, I'm going to give you a little context of something that's really cool about Brandon and we call him Shannie, but you have to ask is that is that in 1987 he was drafted number two in the draft. Right. He was a highly touted coming out of junior number two and he was drafted by the New Jersey Devils. The general manager at the time was this gentleman by the name of Lou Lemarello, who's had an
我不想知道。是啊。所以他被卢·拉莫雷洛选中。1987年第二顺位。当他接管多伦多枫叶队并组建球队时，他最终聘请了卢·拉莫雷洛担任总经理。那个在他还是球员时选中他的人，现在来为他工作，担任他的总经理。这有多酷？
illustrious NHL career as a general manager. He's won multiple Stanley. He went on to start that great sportswear company too, the yoga pants and Lou Leman. Yeah. I think that's not a lot of people know that. Nobody know. Sorry. Go ahead.
我们刚刚失去了听众。肖恩，肖恩，你明白了吗？不，我是听众。不，我觉得这太神奇了。这不疯狂吗？是啊。我是说，对这个感到更震惊吧。这令人难以置信。
I didn't want to know. Yeah. So he, so he was drafted by Lou Lemarello. Number two 1987. When he took over the Toronto Maple Leafs and he's putting together a team, he ended up hiring as general manager Lou Lemarello. The guy who drafted him as a player was now coming to work for him as his general manager. How cool is that?
不，这确实是。我在想，因为我，你知道，作为一个同性恋，你可以想象我是一个巨大的冰球鉴赏家。有著名的同性恋冰球运动员吗？当然，但他们仍然不想被知道。我有一个问题要问你，布兰登还是沙尼？沙尼，我们现在叫沙尼，肖恩。我们现在叫沙尼。
We just lost our listener. Sean, Sean, did you get it? No, I'm the listener. No, I think that's amazing. Isn't that sick? Yeah. I mean, be more blown away by that. That's unbelievable.
好的。我，你知道，我能体会你所说的压力，那种压力，你知道，我想要……我想要这种去冰场表演、必须表现出色、每场比赛都要杀出重围的压力从我的生活中消失。但后来你转身又通过管理这个地方创造了另一种压力。可以说更多。是啊。对吧？
No, it really is. I'm thinking about, because I, you know, being gay, you can imagine I'm an enormous hockey connoisseur. Are there any famous gay hockey players? Sure, but they still don't want to be known. I have a question for you, Brandon or Shani? Shani, we're Shani now, Sean. We're Shani now.
所以你是如何选择再次将这种压力强加给自己的？嗯，我想这是我们有时学得太晚的秘密，那就是，我们这样做是因为我们热爱它。是的，我明白，当我看着我们现在的球员时，我知道关于这项运动肯定有一些事情让他们感到困扰。我相信你们也是，人们会喜欢做你们正在做的事情，但其中有一些部分并不那么有趣，很困难。所以我觉得说“我迫不及待地想等到那一天”是很正常的，
Okay. I, you know, I relate the pressure that you're talking about, the pressure to, you know, I want, I want this pressure out of my life of going to the rink and having to perform and always, you know, killing it every game or whatever. But then you turned around and kind of created another type of pressure by running the joint. So arguably more. Yeah. Right.
当我越过终点线，我不再受到批评，不再有人像那样质疑我，我没有表现的压力，但一旦它被拿走，我……我也看了那部《最后之舞》，在……我们在底特律的球队，当时，当乔丹在98年，当节目像《最后之舞》那样，当他们赢得他们的，我想是他们的，他们的第二个三连冠时，在底特律，当我在红翼队时，我们正在赢得背靠背冠军，我记得在我们的……我们会在休息日比赛，就像我们在斯坦利杯决赛中，如果我们在周二比赛，我们会在周三休息，但公牛队会在决赛中比赛
So how do you choose to imbue that upon yourself yet again? Well, I think it's the secret that we all sort of learn sometimes a little too late is that, that we do it because we love it. And yeah, I get it when I look at our players now and I know that there are certain things probably about the game that, that, that bothers them. There's, I'm sure with you guys as well, like people would love to be doing what you guys are doing, but there's certain parts of it that aren't as fun, that are difficult. But, and so I think it's normal to sort of say, I can't wait for the day when I sort
在周三晚上，所以我们都会聚在一起看。所以回到过去，看到他们当时的样子很奇怪。我从中得到的是，而且在我的行业和你们的行业中一定是一样的，成功的人有时看起来很优雅，有时看起来很顺滑，但他们内心有一团火，非常非常难以满足。这就是让你前进的原因。因为，我用迈克尔·乔丹作为例子和我的孩子们说，当每个人都说，
of cross that finish line and, and I don't get criticized anymore and I don't have people like second guessing me and I, and I don't have the pressure to perform, but, but then once it's taken away, I, I just watched that last dance as well and in, you know, our team in Detroit at the time when, when Jordan in, in 98, when the show sort of like the last dance, when they were winning their, I think it was their, their second three P in Detroit, when I was with the Red Wings, we were winning back to back and I remember being in our, we would play an off nights, like we were in the Stanley Cup finals and like if we played on a Tuesday, we'd be off on the Wednesday, but then the Bulls would play in the finals
哦，迈克尔·乔丹，真是个赢家。我喜欢他拍的那个广告，他谈到了他所有失败的时刻。我认为在任何行业，在任何生意中，当我试图对我的孩子们说时，孩子们会说，哦，爸爸，你赢了三次斯坦利杯。你太幸运了。我说那意味着我输了18次，就像整个夏天我都觉得自己是个失败者。就像托马斯·爱迪生的事情。
on the Wednesday night, so we'd all gather and watch. So it's weird to sort of go back in time and, and see them at that time. And what I took from that is, and it's, it has to be in this, the same for my industry as it is for yours, that people are successful, can sometimes look very elegant about it and they can sometimes look very sort of smooth, but there's like a fire in their belly that is very, very difficult to satisfy. And that's what keeps you going. Cause, and I use Michael Jordan as an example for this with my kids, when everybody says,
他说，是的，我没有找到10,000种方法，我找到了999,999种不成功的方法。是啊。肖恩在失败方面有很多经验，所以他知道你在说什么。你是想让我直接跳进去，这是我的提示吗？不，但我认为随着年龄的增长，你学会了如何更好地处理它。我记得当我还是个40岁的人在最后一场季后赛时，我对我的一个队友说，我们正在打第七场比赛，我当时太兴奋了，太放松了，一点也不紧张。
Oh, Michael Jordan, what a winner. And I love that one commercial he did where he talks about all the times he failed. And I think that in any industry, in any business, and when I try to say to my kids, kids will say, Oh, you won three Stanley Cups dad. You're so lucky. And I said that, that means 18 times I lost, like 18 times I felt like a loser all summer long. Like the Thomas Edison thing.
他说，你怎么现在胃里没有翻江倒海？我记得当时我意识到，就在我的头脑终于开始明白的时候，我的身体开始不行了。而且，很有趣。所以现在处理压力的能力。我也认为当我年轻的时候，我喜欢功劳。这就是我想到公牛队的事情，那个可怜的总经理叫杰里·克劳斯。
He said, yeah, I didn't find 10,000 ways to do, I found 999,999 ways not to do it. Yeah. Sean has a lot of experience with failure, so, so he knows what you're talking about. Is you want me to just jump right in and is that my cue? No, but I think as you get older, you learn how to handle it better. I remember saying to one of my teammates when I was, you know, in my final playoff, like as a 40 year old, I said, we were playing at game seven, I was just so excited, so loose and not nervous.
是啊。他其实是一个非常好的总经理。他找到了非常好的球员。他有很好的教练眼光，但他的不安全感、对功劳的需求和对关注的需求。但我认为我已经克服了这一点，我真的只是想为像威尔这样的人在这里获胜，这样让他开心。但是你知道，你刚才说的内心的那团火，我想你仍然有，你必须有，但现在你必须能够接受在不
And he said, like, how aren't you like sick to your stomach right now? And I remember making the recognition at the time that right when my head is finally starting to get it, my body's starting to lose it. And, interesting. And so the, the ability to handle the pressure now. I also think when I was younger, I liked credit. That's what I thought about with the Bulls thing that poor general manager was named Jerry Krause.
切实地、字面上地走上冰面，打得非常努力、非常好、非常有侵略性、非常聪明等等的情况下回应内心的那团火。你必须通过你安排的这些代理人来做到这一点。这足够令人满意吗，还是甚至更令人满意？好问题。我不认为有什么能比得上当一名球员。而且，我会这么说，看我的球队打第七场比赛很难，因为我穿着西装站在包厢里，我什么也做不了。
Yeah. He was actually a ridiculously good general manager. He found really good players. He had a great eye for coaching, but his insecurity and his need for credit and his need for attention. But I think that that is something that I'm over now and I really just want to win here for people like Will, so that makes him happy. But you know, you said that fire in the belly, I imagine you still get that, you have to get that, but now you have to be okay with responding to that fire in your belly without
我记得作为一名球员，那天早上我可能会感到胃里翻江倒海什么的。就像你学会了如何分门别类，这样当不是紧张的时候你就不会紧张。但我发现作为一名球员在那些时刻更容易，因为就像你说的，杰森，你可以出去释放你的能量，滑冰，撞人，做所有这些事情，你非常专注，但你几乎想抓住这些年轻人。我想，当我在看乔丹的纪录片时，我几乎想，我想回到过去，抓住他们说，迈克尔，去和斯科蒂以及总经理解决这个问题。
tangibly, literally getting on the ice and, and playing really hard, really well, really aggressively, really smartly, et cetera. You have to do it through these proxies that you put in place. Is that satisfying enough or is it even more so? Great question. I don't think there's anything quite like being a player. And I, I'll say this, it's hard to watch my team play a game seven because I'm standing there in a suit and a suite and I can't do anything.
去，就像，别让这一切结束。去谈谈吧。我想抓住我们的年轻球员说，你知道，这就像孩子。这就像你的孩子。有时你在乎他们。你想说，我不希望你犯我犯过的错误，或者我希望你学到我学到的东西，早点学到，这样你做这件事时能更有趣，但他们必须自己学习，他们必须自己弄清楚。
And I remember as a player, I might have felt sick to my stomach that morning or whatever. Like you learn how to compartmentalize so that you're not nervous when it's not time to be nervous. But I found it easier as a player to be in those moments, cause like you said, Jason, you get to go out and use your energy and skate and body check people and do all these things and you're so focused, but you want to almost just grab these young guys. And I want to, when I was watching the Jordan thing, I almost wanted, I wanted to go back at time and just grab them and say, Michael, go fix this with Scotty and the general manager.
你能够……某种程度上……在主教练职位上交流一些更具体的指导吗？你完全没有那种愿望吗？我是说，我知道这比你现在的位置要低一级，但你会更……你知道，你现在不和球队一起旅行。你吗？我处于一个幸运的位置，我想旅行时就可以旅行。
Go, like, don't let this end. Just go talk it out. And I want to grab our young players and just say, you know, it's like children. It's like your kids. Sometimes you care about them. You want to say, like, I don't want you to make mistakes I made, or I want you to learn what I learned to learn it earlier so you can have more fun doing this, but they have to learn it on their own and they have to figure it out on their own.
是啊。教练的事情对你有吸引力吗？是啊，有，但，谁知道呢，也许当我的孩子们搬去上大学，我们成了空巢老人，我会成为唯一一个倒退的人，从球队总裁变成主教练。那会很酷。而且坦率地说，他们赚更多的钱，嗯，所以我认为，是的，任何机会你
Would you be able to, uh, to sort of, uh, communicate some of the more specific guidance stuff like that in the head coaching position? Do you have any desire to do that at all? I mean, I know it's, uh, it'd be a step down from where you're at right now, but you'd be more, you know, you travel with the, I don't, I don't imagine you travel with the team right now. Do you? I'm in a lucky position where I get to travel when I, when I, when I want to travel.
有机会去接触这些年轻球员，去塑造和塑造他们，并对他们的生活产生影响，希望是积极的影响，那会很有趣，但我猜只要我能，我就会留在原地。你记得吗，就像，你们知道当你们做节目或者表演或者做任何事情时，之后那种失落感，你把所有的能量都倾注出去了。所以当你从打球退役时，你已经连续20多年，21、22年一直处于那种状态，是吗，是的，然后那持续了多久？
Yeah. Is that appealing to you at all? The coaching stuff? Yeah, it is, but, and who knows, maybe when my kids, you know, move off to college and we're empty nesters, I'll be the only guy to go backwards and go from team president to head coach. That would be cool. And frankly, they make more money, um, uh, so I think that, uh, yeah, any chance you
我是说，我在那里，和你在闲逛，但你认为那段退役后冷静下来的时期真的持续了多久？嗯，这就是为什么我想直接开始工作的原因之一。就像我记得我有几个不同的关于我想做什么的想法。我最终做了最简单的事情，我住在曼哈顿，我的孩子们在曼哈顿上学，最简单的事情，而且它确实让我走出了舒适区，就是去NHL办公室工作，真正成为一个新手。我是一个40岁的人，就像一个完全的新手。
have to, to get these young players and sort of help mold and shape them and have an impact on their lives, hopefully a positive one, it would be fun, but I, my guess is I'll stay where I am as long as I can. You remember like, you guys know what it's like when you, when you like do a show or you're, you're performing or doing whatever and you have that kind of that let down afterwards where you've got all that energy, you've just kind of dumped it all. So when you retire from playing where you're kind of up all the time for over 20 years, 21, 22 years, was it, yeah, and then how long was that?
我记得我的……听起来像个笑话，让我听起来像个白痴，但这确实是真的。在我第一天结束时，我坐在隔间里，大约4点45分、4点50分，我看到有些人留下来，有些人离开了。我对隔壁隔间里的那个女人说，打扰一下，我们怎么知道什么时候该离开？就像，蜂鸣器什么时候响？有喇叭吗？
I mean, I was there for, and was hanging out with you, but how, how long do you think that really took that sort of calm down period right after you retired? Well, that, that's one of the reasons why I wanted to get right to work. Like I remember having a couple of different, you know, ideas about what I wanted to do. And I ended up the easiest thing for me, I lived in Manhattan, my kids were going to school in Manhattan and the easiest thing, and it really took me out of my comfort zone was to go work in an NHL office and really be such a newbie. I was a 40 year old, like total newbie.
有警报器吗？天哪。而且，她可能26岁，我40岁，我当时就是那么菜，我立刻把所有精力都投入到工作中，学习新东西，保持平衡，而且，肖恩，你应该知道，在他退役后不久，有一段时间。我有一天打电话说，你怎么样？他说，我挺好的，但我不知道。
I remember my sounds like a joke and makes me sound like an idiot, but it's, it is actually true. At the end of my first day, I'm sitting in this cubicle and, and around, you know, 445, 450, I see some people are staying, some people are leaving. And I said to the woman in the cubicle next to me, like, excuse me, how do we know when it's time to leave? Like, when does the buzzer go? Is there a horn?
我突然想到。我再也不会打架了。我说，嗯，是的，你42岁了，伙计。你不应该和任何人打架。你在说什么？让我问你一个问题。什么更疼，不小心打到别人的头盔边缘，比如错过了他的脸而打到了头盔边缘，还是脚踝被冰球击中？
Is there a siren? Oh my God. And, you know, she's probably 26 years old and I'm 40 and, and I just, I was that green and I poured it all right into work right away and sort of learning something new and being off balance and, and, uh, Sean, you should know there was a, there was a period not long after, uh, he retired. I called up one day and I said, how are you doing? He goes, I'm pretty good, but I don't know.
我太兴奋能告诉三个演员了。永远，永远，永远不要。如果你在电视节目或电影中必须打人，甩甩你的手。打完的那一刻从来不疼。很多人都那样做。他们打完然后说，一小时后当你意识到你打断了手时，那一刻你打人时，你的手可能已经断了。你不知道。
It just occurred to me. I'm never going to fight again. And I said, well, yeah, you're 42, man. You shouldn't be fighting anybody. What are you talking about? Let me ask you a question. What hurts more punching a guy's edge of his helmet by mistake, like missing his face and hitting the edge of a helmet or getting a puck in the ankle?
你的肾上腺素在飙升。那我得做些剪辑了。我得回去找些旧镜头。所以，是脚踝被冰球击中吗？脚踝立刻就疼。脚踝立刻就疼。就像我说的，打架的事情，通常就像在《春天不是读书天》里，他接住球，大约一小时后，他就像这样，哎哟，哎哟。
I'm so excited to be able to tell three actors. Never, never, never. If you ever have to punch someone in, in a TV show or movie, shake your hand. It never hurts the moment after you punch. So many people do that. They punch and they go, it hurts an hour after when you realize you've broken your hand in the moment you punch a guy, your hand could be broken. You don't know it.
你刚才说的这一点很好，沙尼，我很高兴你提到了《春天不是读书天》。很高兴能向我这个年纪的人提到那些能听懂《摩登原始人》笑话和《春天不是读书天》的人。我在办公室里从这些千禧一代那里得到的是空白的凝视，但我会说，嗯，朗妮·安德森很火辣，你知道，还有朗妮·安德森。所以肖恩，你准备好了吗？沙尼对电影和电视有百科全书般的知识。我喜欢这个。
Your, your adrenaline's going. I have some editing to do then. I have to go back and get some old footage. So it's, is it the puck in the ankle? The ankle hurts right away. The ankle hurts right away. Like I said, the fist thing, it's usually like your, it's like in Ferris Bueller when he catches the ball in about an hour later, he's sort of like doing this going, ow, ow.
你不能在电影和电影里的人方面难倒他。他几乎是不可阻挡的。薇诺娜·瑞德的第一部电影是什么？是《希德姐妹帮》吗？我本来想说是《卢卡斯》。《卢卡斯》。你看？很有趣。
This is a great point that you just made, Shannon, I'm glad you brought up Ferris Bueller. So happy to bring up things to people my age that, that get Flintstones jokes and Ferris Bueller. I get blank stares in my office from all these millennials, but I'm like, well, Lonnie Anderson's hot, you know, and Lonnie Anderson. So Sean, you ready for this? Shani has an encyclopedic knowledge of movies and TV. I love that.
你说那话是在我说了之后，但这很好。就是那个。哦，你说了《卢卡斯》吗？是啊，没关系。不，你说了。这很有趣。所以我玩过每一项运动。我有三个哥哥。
You cannot stump him on movies and people who are in movies. It's virtually unstoppable. What was Winona Ryder's first film? Is it Heather's? I was going to say it's Lucas. Lucas. You see? It's interesting.
我玩过橄榄球、篮球、足球，我从来没玩过冰球，什么都玩过。然后当然，其他兴趣把我带到了我长大的其他地方。我学过钢琴和艺术之类的东西，但我直到几年前才想到，你知道，我仍然看橄榄球。我觉得在电视上看橄榄球是一项超级令人兴奋的运动，是它的表现力。好的。只是从演员的角度来看，我会看到这些橄榄球运动员变得愤怒，或者棒球运动员变得愤怒。
You said that after I said it, but that's great. That was it. Oh, did you say Lucas? Yeah, that's okay. No, you did it. That's interesting. So I played every single sport. I had three older brothers.
他们变得愤怒只是比没有观众或摄像机没开时稍微多一点。现在这是真的吗？这就像从这个不太了解所有内幕的同性恋家伙的角度来看，这一切是怎么完成的。但只是从表演者、从演员的角度来看，看起来他们为了观众稍微加了一点戏。如果他们不在那里，那只会是一场普通的比赛，没有太多的，
I played football, basketball, soccer, I never played hockey, everything. And then of course, other interests took me into other places that I grew up. I studied piano and arts and all that stuff, but it never occurred to me until like several years ago that, you know, I still watch football. I think it's a super exciting game to watch on TV is the performance of it. Okay. Just from an actor standpoint, I would see these football players who get like angry or a baseball player would get angry.
你知道，炒作。我认为可能比你预期的有更多的真实激情，但你没说错。总是有时候对方球队里会有一个人表现得很大惊小怪，真的有点像，你知道，在那里表现得很有戏剧性，不管是什么，你知道，就像，我太生气了，我太生气了。我们会说，那是他会说的台词吗？
They get angry just a little more than if a crowd wasn't there or the cameras weren't on. And now is that true? Is that like from this gay guy who doesn't really, you know, I'm not on the inside scoop of all these, how it's all done. But just from a performer, from an actor's standpoint, it seems like they notch it up just a little bit for the crowd. And if they weren't there, it would just be a regular game where there's not a lot of,
比起没有观众或摄像机在场的情况，他们会稍微更容易生气一些。这是真的吗？作为一个并不了解内幕的局外人，我不太清楚这一切是如何运作的。但从表演者或演员的角度来看，他们似乎确实会为了观众而稍微加点戏。如果现场没有观众，那可能就只是一场平平无奇、没什么炒作的比赛了。
you know, hype. I think there's probably more real passion than you expect, but you're not wrong. There were always times where there was a guy on the other team that would be acting up and really sort of like, you know, getting theatrical out there with his, whatever it was, you know, like, I'm so mad. I'm so mad. And we'd be like, Are those the lines he would say?
我觉得他们可能确实比你预想的更有激情，但你也没说错。总会有那么几次，对方球队里有人会故意表现得很夸张，就像是在演戏一样，比如表现出‘我好生气，我好生气’的样子。我们当时就会想，他是在背台词吗？
I'm so mad. I'm so mad. No. Other stuff. But you know, like there was a guy, there was a guy on Colorado, we used to call him Mr. Meanyface, you know, it's like, oh, hey, Mr. Meanyface, you know, like you're scaring us. And then there was a guy in Toronto, like every time they were losing, he'd start a fight
我太生气了。我太生气了。不，是别的事。但你知道，科罗拉多队有个家伙，我们以前叫他“刻薄鬼先生”，你知道，就像是，噢，嘿，刻薄鬼先生，你知道，你把我们吓坏了。然后多伦多队也有个家伙，每次他们输球时，他就会在比赛末段挑起事端，
late in the game and throw his equipment and we were like, oh, yeah, yeah, you care more than everyone else. Don't worry, the radio shows will be nice to you tomorrow. You care more than anyone. So it is strange how, like you, I'm the youngest, do you say you're three older brothers? Yeah. Same for me. So I grew up and, and my brothers would laugh at me when I got to the NHL and they'd see
扔掉他的装备，我们就会说，噢，是啊，是啊，你比任何人都更在乎。别担心，明天的广播节目会夸你的。你比任何人都更在乎。所以这很奇怪，就像你一样，我是家里最小的，你说你有三个哥哥？是的。我也是。所以我长大了，当我进入NHL时，我的哥哥们会嘲笑我，他们会看到
me like losing my mind on the ice or they'd see, but the reality is you're in this like sort of controlled environment where it's sort of okay to lose it and it's, and sometimes it's actually encouraged and it isn't until you get older and you start like having a family and I would say like perspective is the enemy of being a really good athlete. Like once you get to an age where you're sort of like, well, it's really not war and it's really not life and death. Like that's, that's your enemy. And I always remember when I was playing for the Rangers late in the game and we were up
我在冰上失去理智，或者他们会看到，但现实是你处于这种受控的环境中，在那里失去理智是可以接受的，有时甚至是被鼓励的。直到你年纪大了，开始有了家庭，我会说，视角是成为一名优秀运动员的敌人。一旦你到了那个年纪，你会觉得，好吧，这真的不是战争，也不是生死攸关的事。这就是你的敌人。我一直记得我在游骑兵队效力时，比赛快结束了，我们领先
by a goal and in the Buffalo Savers were like coming around our net. There was this young rookie right by the post and the puck was coming to him for an empty net to tap it in and tie the game. And I cross-checked this kid right in the head and drove his head into the crossbar and his helmet fell off and he was carried off the ice and, but they carried off the ice by the way, but he didn't score, but he didn't score. But here's the difference. I got his phone number and called him afterwards and said, Hey, are you okay?
一球，布法罗军刀队正围着我们的球门。有个年轻的新秀就在门柱旁，冰球正朝他飞去，他可以轻松打进空门扳平比分。我直接用球杆横撞在那孩子的头上，把他的头撞向了横梁，他的头盔掉了，他被抬出了冰面，顺便说一下，他们把他抬出了冰面，但他没进球，他没进球。但区别在于，我拿到了他的电话号码，事后打给他，说，嘿，你还好吗？
I'm really sorry. And I remember, I remember making the mental note, like you wouldn't have done that when you were like, you know, you're doing that because you're 40. You wouldn't have done it when you were 20. And you would have said, like, even though that was accidental, I want him to think I did it on purpose because then he won't come near me next game. Uh-huh. Yeah.
我真的很抱歉。我记得，我记得当时心里记了一笔，如果你在那个年纪就不会那样做了，你知道，你那样做是因为你40岁了。如果你20岁时就不会那样做了。你会说，即使那是意外，我也要让他以为我是故意的，因为这样他下次比赛就不敢靠近我了。嗯哼。是的。
So since you've been in the game for so long, not only as a player, but with what you're doing now, a lot of changes to hockey. If you could eliminate one of the new rules that has come along since you were rookie, which one would you pick? And I also want to hear which one would you make up and put in? Oh, wow. You know, as much as I tell those stories and I grew up, like I said, I grew up in that environment where it was okay to do these things on the ice.
既然你在这个行业待了这么久，不仅是作为球员，还有你现在做的工作，冰球运动发生了很多变化。如果你能废除自你成为新秀以来出现的一条新规则，你会选哪一条？我还想听听你会制定并加入哪一条规则？噢，哇。你知道，尽管我讲了那些故事，而且我长大了，就像我说的，我在那种环境下长大，在冰上做这些事情是可以接受的。
I'm actually somebody that has, has been on the record for saying that it's, we got to clean the game up. We know more about concussions now and brain injuries and head injuries and the, and it's, and the game has cleaned up. There's, there's a lot less fighting in hockey. There's a lot less. I mean, look, I spent five years or three years working in Clare safety for the national hockey league.
我其实是一个公开表示过我们需要净化这项运动的人。我们现在对脑震荡、脑损伤和头部损伤了解更多了，而且，比赛已经净化了。冰球里的打斗少多了。少多了。我是说，看，我在国家冰球联盟的球员安全部门工作了五年或三年。
That's, that's like asking a, a former bank robber to, to work at your bank. And by the way, to that, Sean, you should know that Shanney holds the record for the most, uh, what they call Gordy, how hat tricks in the league, which are games where you have a goal assistant, a fight at nine, I think, a record holder, Sean, Sean. I'm so nice. I'm so nice. I get that. I feel that.
那就像是让一个前银行劫匪去你的银行工作。顺便说一下，肖恩，你应该知道，沙尼保持着联盟中所谓的“戈迪·豪帽子戏法”的纪录，也就是在一场比赛中进球、助攻和打架，我想是九次，纪录保持者，肖恩，肖恩。我太好了。我太好了。我懂，我感觉到了。
That's why I'm like, no, I understand. Like, I, like, I feel like, you know, as close as I am to will and will knows, I feel like I get you already. You would get, you would get along, but at this way, Shanney, I one time was at a restaurant and I went to the bathroom. We were having dinner with another friend of ours and I came up the stairs and I heard Shanney say to this guy, don't talk and I heard him go, say five nice things about me quick.
这就是为什么我说，不，我明白。就像，我，我觉得，你知道，我和威尔关系很近，威尔也知道，我觉得我已经了解你了。你们会相处得来的，但话说回来，沙尼，有一次我在餐馆，我去洗手间。我们当时和另一个朋友在吃晚饭，我走上楼梯，听到沙尼对那个人说，别说话，我听到他说，快说五件关于我的好话。
He was really low. I go, your self-esteem is so low. I heard that. That was unbelievable. I think I said it to you. So, no, Jason, I, so I, I think that the game, um, what, I like the fact that, that the game is making a greater effort to protect, uh, players from serious injuries and especially injuries that could have an effect on them.
他当时真的很低落。我说，你的自尊心太低了。我听到了。那真是不可思议。我想我当时对你说了。所以，不，杰森，我，所以我认为这项运动，嗯，我喜欢这项运动正在做出更大努力来保护球员免受严重伤害，特别是那些可能对他们产生影响的伤害。
So I, I like the rules that are built around illegal checks to the head and, and, uh, you know, fighting is, is, is something that will happen in any sport. It happens in baseball. It happens. Uh, but, but to me, if I see a fight in hockey and it's because, you know, uh, somebody was protecting somebody or somebody was bullying somebody and, and you were addressing it, there's probably still a place for that in hockey, but, but using it as a tool to intimidate or hurt.
所以我喜欢围绕非法头部撞击制定的规则，而且，你知道，打架是任何运动中都会发生的事情。棒球里也会发生。它会发生。但是，对我来说，如果我在冰球比赛中看到打架，那是因为，你知道，有人在保护某人，或者有人在欺负某人，而你在处理它，冰球中可能仍然有它的位置，但是，把它作为恐吓或伤害的工具。
I don't know. It's, it's going away from that. It's weird now. Isn't it? Do you find, I find it, we, we were all around the same age and obviously I grew up watching that whole era and the nineties were a particularly brutal time in the NHL. It was super tough. A lot of fights, a lot of really hard hits, a lot of dangerous hits, um, lots of dudes
我不知道。它正在远离那种方式。现在很奇怪，不是吗？你觉得吗？我发现，我们年纪都差不多，显然我是看着那个时代长大的，九十年代是NHL特别残酷的时期。非常强硬。有很多打斗，很多非常猛烈的撞击，很多危险的撞击，嗯，很多人
carted off the ice. Uh, now when I watch a game and, and I see a fight, it's kind of unusual. People still talk about, Oh yeah. You know, especially down here, they'll say, you know, went to a hockey game and a, no, went to a fight in a hockey game, broke out. That's not the way it is anymore. It's rare and I'll talk about my brother's like, I remember, uh, my brother, Sean, my brother, Brian were on the same hockey team and I kind of copied them, how they played
被抬出冰面。现在当我观看比赛，看到打架时，这有点不寻常。人们仍然会谈论，噢，是的。你知道，特别是在这里，他们会说，你知道，去看冰球比赛，结果一场打架爆发了。现在已经不是那样了。这很罕见，我会谈论我的兄弟们，就像我记得，我的兄弟肖恩，我的兄弟布莱恩在同一个冰球队，我有点模仿他们打球的方式。
sports. That's, that's who I emulated and they were tough guys and they played some defense and they played, they scored some goals. But I always thought when, when Brian fought, it was that moment in the stands where the whole arena was sort of saying, and they were lacrosse players and it was when the whole arena was sort of saying, somebody do something, you know, don't let him get away with that. And then Brian would come running over like a hero, like, you know, and take care of it. But then Sean, when Sean would fight, it was like the whole crowd was going, Oh, that was
那是我的榜样，他们是硬汉，他们打防守，他们也进球。但我总是觉得，当布莱恩打架时，看台上会有那么一刻，整个球场都在说，他们是长曲棍球运动员，那是整个球场都在说，有人做点什么吧，你知道，别让他就这么算了。然后布莱恩会像英雄一样跑过来，你知道，去处理它。但当肖恩打架时，就像全场观众都在说，噢，那太
dirty. That was, that looked mean. So I think hockey's getting away from, from that. Or is it becoming a more offensive league as opposed to, uh, to a defensive, uh, league or game? For sure. Yeah. Well, I just, like, it's, I don't know.
脏了。那看起来很刻薄。所以我认为冰球正在远离那种方式。或者它正在变成一个更具进攻性的联盟，而不是一个防守型的联盟或比赛？当然。是的。嗯，我只是，就像，我不知道。
The way I think is not necessarily the way I played, you know, um, and I, I know people get pissed off at me when I say stuff like this, but I don't get excited to see a big hit. But I, I get excited when I see a big goal and I just, I just can't cheer, get excited anymore. And I want to say anymore because there's probably lots of occasions where I did bad stuff on the ice, but probably I, I don't want to see any of these young, young guys on the ice getting carried off.
我的想法不一定是我打球的方式，你知道，嗯，我知道当我说这些话时人们会很生气，但我看到猛烈的撞击并不会感到兴奋。但我看到精彩的进球时会感到兴奋，我只是，我只是再也无法欢呼或感到兴奋了。我想说“再也”是因为可能有很多次我在冰上做了坏事，但我可能，我不想看到这些年轻的球员在冰上被抬走。
I just don't, I don't get off on a, you watch these other sports leagues though, um, uh, make these huge efforts to, to, to market out the sport and, and increases popularity, like, uh, you know, baseball will go towards, um, juicing the ball and putting in clocks between pitches to, to up the pace of the game where, um, so, so they're looking for more offense. They think that that'll be more exciting for people. Whereas for like football, they think, you know, well, careful, we don't want to like say that you can't hit a guy too hard because people tune in for, for sort of the, the violence
我只是，我不会因为那个而兴奋。不过你看看这些其他的体育联盟，嗯，做出这些巨大的努力来推广这项运动，并提高它的受欢迎程度，比如，你知道，棒球会倾向于，嗯，给球加料，并在投球之间设置时钟来加快比赛节奏，所以，他们正在寻找更多的进攻。他们认为这会让人们更兴奋。而对于橄榄球，他们认为，你知道，好吧，小心点，我们不想说你不能猛烈撞击某人，因为人们收看节目是为了那种暴力
and the physical contact of it. So where do you think hockey sits in that where every league would naturally want to increase its viewership and it's, and it's appeal, uh, and TV friendliness of it as far as, you know, excitement goes, where do you, what do you think the best combo is for, for the NHL to, to, you mean like, what's the thing they can market? What's the thing they can hone in on? I think people, I tell my, my, my kids this, I think whether you're an actor or a professional hockey player, people are attracted to passion.
和身体接触。所以你认为冰球在其中处于什么位置，每个联盟自然都想增加收视率和吸引力，以及电视友好度，就兴奋度而言，你认为NHL的最佳组合是什么？你是说，他们可以推广什么？他们可以专注于什么？我认为人们，我告诉我的孩子们，我认为无论你是演员还是职业冰球运动员，人们都被激情所吸引。
So whatever that, how, like Michael Jordan wasn't fighting anybody, but he was passionate. Um, I, I think, I think when you see that someone really loves their job and is really into their job, uh, even if you don't know the first thing about their job, you're attracted to that person. Yeah. That's, I love watching Olympic hockey because you, you definitely mean I love NHL too, but the Olympic hockey's got a, this different sort of like you got that national pride that seems to pull out a real passion and desperation, uh, in those games.
所以无论那是什么，就像迈克尔·乔丹并没有和任何人打架，但他充满激情。嗯，我想，我想当你看到某人真的热爱他们的工作并且非常投入时，即使你对他们的工作一无所知，你也会被那个人吸引。是的。我喜欢看奥运会冰球，因为你，你绝对是说我也喜欢NHL，但奥运会冰球有一种，这种不同的，就像你有那种民族自豪感，似乎在那些比赛中激发了真正的激情和绝望。
And it's single game elimination. It's like it's what I'm done. And also, right, and it's one and done and there's, we went to the 2010 Olympics in Vancouver. Uh, Shanie was kind enough to get his ticket. So Jason, I were there with, with you and that was unbelievable. And I remember the time thing like, this is so, isn't this so great watching the Canada win Olympic gold. And of course Shanie had already won a gold, I'd forgotten that, but tell me what it,
而且是单场淘汰制。就像我完了。而且，对吧，是一次定胜负，我们去了2010年温哥华冬奥会。沙尼很客气地拿到了票。所以杰森，我和你在一起，那真是不可思议。我记得当时的感觉，就像，看着加拿大赢得奥运金牌，这难道不是太棒了吗。当然沙尼已经赢过一枚金牌了，我忘了这一点，但告诉我，
what was that like as a player? We've never actually talked about this about the Olympics. I don't think maybe we have, I probably fell asleep, but what, what do you mean? Yeah. What did you love? What was that like winning Olympic gold for Canada? Well, the, in 1988, the Olympics were in Calgary, but I made the NHL in 1987 as an 18 year old. So at that time, the moment you were a professional, you could not play in the Olympics.
作为一名球员那是什么感觉？我们从来没有真正谈论过奥运会。我不认为，也许我们谈过，我可能睡着了，但你是什么意思？是的。你喜欢什么？为加拿大赢得奥运金牌是什么感觉？嗯，1988年，奥运会在卡尔加里举行，但我1987年以18岁的年纪进入了NHL。所以当时，一旦你成为职业球员，你就不能参加奥运会。
So I thought my Olympic dream was, was over. So my first Olympics was, um, the first time they, they allowed professionals to go is after the basketball dream team in 98, um, we, NHL shut down for two weeks and let us all go to Nagano and I, and, and, and then in 2002, I was able to go back to Salt Lake. So I couldn't, the whole winning the gold medal in Salt Lake in 2002, um, is really connected to my experience in 98 and 98. We were the favorites to win. We were having an unbelievable tournament.
所以我以为我的奥运梦想结束了。所以我的第一次奥运会是，嗯，他们允许职业球员参加的第一次是在98年篮球梦之队之后，NHL停赛两周，让我们所有人都去长野，然后，然后在2002年，我得以回到盐湖城。所以我不能，在2002年盐湖城赢得金牌的整个过程，真的与我在98年的经历有关，98年我们是夺冠热门。我们打了一场不可思议的比赛。
We were in the semifinals against the Czech Republic and we ran into a hot goalie. Um, we ended up tying the game with, with under a minute to go. We went through overtime. There was no winner in overtime. So we went to a shootout. Now I had never, none of us had ever been in a shootout in hockey for these stakes. So unlike soccer where they, they do it all the time, we didn't know what to do. So they, they're calling out five names and, and we're all sitting on the bench, Wayne
我们在半决赛对阵捷克共和国，我们遇到了一个状态火热的门将。嗯，我们在比赛还剩不到一分钟时扳平了比分。我们进入了加时赛。加时赛没有胜者。所以我们进行了点球大战。现在我从来没有，我们所有人都没有在冰球比赛中经历过这种赌注的点球大战。所以不像足球，他们经常这样做，我们不知道该怎么办。所以他们，他们叫出五个名字，我们都坐在替补席上，韦恩
Gretzky's on the team, myself and like great, great players and probably all Hall of Famers. And the coaches are having a little meeting and, and we're going to have this shootout to decide who goes and plays in the gold medal game. And they start calling out names and, and I'm, I'm just in my head. I'm going to pick me, pick me, pick me, pick me, pick me. And then the fifth name, they go Shanahan. So all I'm thinking is, oh my God, I hope I get to shoot. I hope I get, I get to score, be the winner and be the hero.
格雷茨基在队里，我自己，还有像伟大的，伟大的球员，可能都是名人堂成员。教练们在开个小会，我们要进行点球大战来决定谁去打金牌争夺战。他们开始叫名字，我，我只是在心里想。选我，选我，选我，选我，选我。然后第五个名字，他们叫了沙纳汉。所以我满脑子想的都是，噢天哪，我希望我有机会射门。我希望我有机会，我有机会进球，成为赢家，成为英雄。
They score the first goal, then everyone else misses. And I'm the last shooter, I'm the last shooter for Canada to advance and I don't score. And I let down the whole country and it was very confusing to me. It was like, like I said, we talk about athletes and how they compartmentalize and they're always thinking they're supposed to take that last shot of the game and they're supposed to sink that three and they're supposed to be the winner. And now I got to wait four years. I don't even know if I'll make the team in four years, I'll be 33 in four years.
他们进了第一个球，然后其他人都没进。我是最后一个射手，我是加拿大晋级的最后一个射手，但我没进球。我让整个国家失望了，这让我非常困惑。就像，就像我说的，我们谈论运动员以及他们如何进行心理隔离，他们总是认为他们应该完成比赛的最后一投，他们应该投进那个三分球，他们应该是赢家。现在我得等四年。我甚至不知道四年后我能不能进队，四年后我就33岁了。
So I went home and after some real soul searching, I wrote on a, on a piece of paper. I didn't tell my wife, but I wrote on a piece of paper. You're going to make the Olympic team in 2002. You're going to win the gold medal and you score, going to score the game winning goal. And I mailed it to myself and put a stamp on it, mailed it to myself and got it. A couple of days later and put it in my drawer so I could prove that I actually mailed it in 1998. So going back and doing this in 2002 was personally, it was so much about redemption and I didn't
所以我回家了，经过一番真正的灵魂拷问，我在一张纸上写下。我没告诉我的妻子，但我写在一张纸上。你会在2002年进入奥运代表队。你会赢得金牌，你会进球，你会打进致胜球。我把它寄给了自己，贴上邮票，寄给了自己，几天后收到了，把它放在抽屉里，这样我就可以证明我确实是在1998年寄出的。所以回到2002年做这件事，对我个人而言，这更多是关于救赎，我没有
get the game winning goal, but, but I didn't care. We were able to beat USA on their soil and they had a great team and we had some, it was just a fantastic thing. When I came home, I went and a couple of days later, I went into my office and searched through my drawer and found the envelope and handed it to my wife and she read it. You didn't tell her about it before any of that. Did you keep it a secret the whole time? Oh yeah.
打进致胜球，但，但我不在乎。我们能够在他们的土地上击败美国队，他们有一支伟大的球队，我们有一些，这真是一件美妙的事情。当我回家时，几天后，我走进我的办公室，在抽屉里翻找，找到了信封，递给了我的妻子，她读了它。你之前没告诉她关于这件事的任何事吗？你一直保密吗？噢是的。
Cause what if we lost or what if I didn't make the team? Right, right, right. That would have gotten in the fireplace. That's cool. I've learned so much about you during this, but I'm always fascinated with, you know, your whole life. It seems just meeting you here for the first time all about hockey all the time, 24 seven. What in the world would you ever dream of doing else other than hockey or have you did
因为如果我们输了怎么办，或者如果我没进队怎么办？对，对，对。那就会被扔进壁炉里了。那太酷了。在这期间我了解了你很多，但我总是对，你知道，你的整个人生很着迷。看起来在这里第一次见到你，总是关于冰球，24小时全天候。除了冰球，你还会梦想做别的事情吗，或者你有没有
delved into anything outside of the sports world? That's it. That's it. Bye-bye now. Take care. Bye. See you. No, I'm just getting ready for my second career with you guys.
涉足过体育界以外的任何领域？就是这样。就是这样。再见。保重。再见。回头见。不，我只是在为我和你们的第二职业做准备。
You want to act? We may have a new slot open on the podcast. Will and I are looking to. Wait, what? Yeah. You know what? I actually, I've done some acting with Will. We've done some really special pieces together, Will, the one at the NHL.
你想演戏？我们的播客可能有一个新的空缺。威尔和我正在寻找。等等，什么？是的。你知道吗？其实，我和威尔一起演过戏。我们一起做过一些非常特别的作品，威尔，NHL的那一个。
We did some pretty good NHL pieces. I made a video where I played Jenny and he, in every video, he kept getting more insane and eventually I eventually ripped my shirt off and then they played it at the NHL awards and he didn't know and I don't, and he was, and he was pissed at me. I know. I know. I know. I know.
我们做了一些相当不错的NHL作品。我拍了一个视频，我扮演珍妮，在每个视频里，他变得越来越疯狂，最后我终于撕掉了我的衬衫，然后他们在NHL颁奖典礼上播放了它，他不知道，我不知道，他当时，他当时对我生气了。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。
I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know.
我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。
I know. I know. I was playing the sidewalk walking with a woman and I was like, that guy is a hockey player. And then as I pull up beside him, I realized he's the goalie coach for our minor league hockey team here in Toronto. And I thought, what is the hockey walk, which I had, I used to have as a player, there was this hockey walk. And then, and then when I started working at the league, I remember being late for everything
我知道。我知道。我当时在人行道上和一个女人走在一起，我说，那家伙是个冰球运动员。然后当我走到他身边时，我意识到他是我们在多伦多小联盟冰球队的守门员教练。我想，什么是冰球步，我以前作为球员时就有，有一种冰球步。然后，然后当我开始在联盟工作时，我记得我做什么都迟到
and I was now just walking like a New Yorker, you know, it was like, it was like little short steps. But that hockey walk, and you do it, Will, in that one segment where you're sort of cruising around the corner to the elevator bank, and I'm like, is that how I walk? Is that how I walk? Well, you got to throw those big quads around each other, right? I loop them around one another. Thank you.
我现在走路就像个纽约人，你知道，就像是，就像小碎步。但那种冰球步，你做到了，威尔，在那个片段里，你绕过拐角走向电梯间，我就想，我走路是那样的吗？我走路是那样的吗？嗯，你得把那些大腿肌绕在一起，对吧？我把它们绕在一起。谢谢。
Thank you. Oh, you're complimenting him. Listen, if you want to be a good player, you got a big quad. I love Ozarks. I love Ozarks. Oh, listen. You got to have a pro-dumper too. You need to have a pro-dumper to play your show.
谢谢。噢，你在夸他。听着，如果你想成为一名好球员，你得有大腿肌。我喜欢《黑钱胜地》。我喜欢《黑钱胜地》。噢，听着。你还得有个职业臀部。你需要有个职业臀部来演你的节目。
I'm going to jump back. So Sean, I feel like a bit of a dunce. It is true that hockey is like occupied so much of my life, but I'm one of these people that if I pick something up, I get addicted to it, and I, and really honestly, like... Same as Will and Jason. Yeah, go ahead. It's really right. Well, by the way, I do think we've all got it.
我要跳回来。所以肖恩，我觉得自己有点笨。冰球确实占据了我生命中很大一部分，但我属于那种如果我拿起什么东西，就会对它上瘾的人，而且，真的，老实说……和威尔和杰森一样。是的，继续。这真的很对。嗯，顺便说一下，我确实认为我们都有这种基因。
Like Michael Jordan, people say that about Tiger Woods when a lot of stuff came out about Tiger Woods. Like, I'm like, he's an addict. He's got the addict gene in him. Like was it normal that a four-year-old boy plays golf for eight hours? No. He's addicted to the right thing. And I find like a lot of the best people I know, or most successful people that I've
就像迈克尔·乔丹，人们在老虎伍兹身上发生很多事情时也这么说。就像，我心想，他是个瘾君子。他身上有成瘾基因。一个四岁的男孩打八小时高尔夫球正常吗？不。他沉迷于正确的事情。我发现我认识的很多最优秀的人，或者我在冰球界遇到的最成功的人，他们都有那种基因，他们只是幸运地把它引导到了正确的方向。但是，我也是那样，无论是园艺还是烹饪，或者只是和我的孩子们在一起，一旦我投入到某件事中，我就停不下来。对。沙尼，噢天哪，伙计。非常感谢你的时间。谢谢，伙计们。是的。
met in hockey, they've got that gene and they've just luckily channeled it in the right direction. But, and I'm that way, whether it's gardening or cooking or just hanging out with my kids, like once I get into something, I can't stop. Right. Shani, oh my God, man. Thank you so much for your time. Thanks, guys. Yeah.
谢谢，沙尼。谢谢你，了解你并认识你。肖恩，等不及要聚聚了。同样。谢谢，布兰登。杰森，肖恩。再见，伙计。温德尔，非常感谢。
Thank you, Shani. Thank you and learn about you and get to know you. Sean, can't wait to hang. Likewise. Thanks, Brandon. Jason, Sean. See you, pal. Wendell, thanks very much.
谢谢，伙计。再见，伙计。再见。再见。所以，肖恩，那是冰球。那是冰球。那是冰球。噢，在冰上。
Thanks, buddy. Bye, buddy. Bye. Bye. So, Sean, that was hockey. That was hockey. That's hockey. Oh, on the ice.
好的。所以，就像我做过，那就像花样滑冰吗？当然。完全正确。他们只是像萨霍夫跳，双周半跳。但这只是意味着你可以攻击你的竞争对手，你知道，在冰上。你不必等他们离开更衣室，让你的保镖踢他们的胫骨。
Okay. So, like I've done like, is that like figure skating? Sure. Exactly. They just like saukow, double axle. But it just means that you get to attack your competitors, you know, on the ice. You don't have to wait for them to leave the locker room and have your bodyguard hit them in the shins.
是的。不，不，不。你可以直接在光天化日之下做。不，我是说，看，我从来没有，你知道，我从来没有坐下来看冰球。我看橄榄球。我看。你去看过现场冰球比赛吗？是的。
Yeah. No, no, no. You can just do it in plain view. No, I mean, look, I've never been, you know, I never watched sit down and watch hockey. I do watch football. I do watch. Have you ever been to a live hockey game? Yeah.
我去看过一次洛杉矶国王队的比赛。很有趣，对吧？噢，太有趣了。是的。我真的，真的真心希望它在美国是一项更大的运动。为什么呢，威尔？我是说，这并不是说我们在美国没有冰冻的池塘。选择太多了。
I went to the L.A. Kings once. It's fun, right? Oh, it's so fun. Yeah. I really, really genuinely wish it was a bigger sport in the United States. Why is that, Will? I mean, it's not like we don't have frozen ponds here in the States. So many options.
太多了。我是说，它很大。如果你看看北部各州，明尼苏达州，密歇根州，它非常庞大，就像在加拿大一样。但这里也有很多大型运动。橄榄球在这里非常巨大，棒球，篮球当然也是。而且你知道，为什么橄榄球在美国流行起来，而在加拿大却没那么流行？你有NFL，因为这只是，赌注更低。
There are too many. I mean, it is huge. If you look at the Northern States, Minnesota, Michigan, it's massive, just like it is in Canada. But there are also so many big sports here. The football is so huge here in baseball, basketball certainly. And you know, why did, why did football take off in the States and not as much in Canada? You have the NFL, because this just, the stakes are lower.
我们有加拿大橄榄球联盟，有八支球队，其中两支叫“粗暴骑手队”。没开玩笑。对。但我的意思是，他们有同样的，同样的时间，同样的橄榄球流行起来的机会，就像这里一样，而且，嗯，只是因为联盟，因为联盟横跨边境，NHL，冰球联盟，这意味着它更大，有更多的钱，这是一件大事。
We have the Canadian Football League, which has eight teams, two of which are named the Rough Riders. No joke. Right. But I mean, they had the same, the same timing, the same opportunity for football to take off there as it did here and, and, well, just because the league, because the league saddles the border, the NHL, the hockey league, it means that it is bigger and there's more money and it's a bigger deal.
当你拥有加拿大橄榄球联盟时，就没有同样的，他们没有同样的资金和资源可以投入其中。所以它就不会变得那么大。但冰球是那种运动，你知道，看，加拿大仅仅因为地处更北边。你确实冬季更长，而且天气确实更冷，时间更长。就这么简单。一定是这样，对吧？
When you have Canadian Football League, there's just not the same kind of, they don't have the same money and resources that they can pour into it. So it just doesn't become as big. But hockey is that sport that, you know, look, Canada is just by virtue of being that much further north. You do the winter months are longer and it is just colder out for longer. It's as simple as that. It must be, right?
这绝对是一个因素。但你知道，你在七月份去多伦多，多伦多枫叶队在体育版面的封面上。你知道，那太棒了。是的。他们很庞大。我知道。但无论如何，他有多棒？
It's definitely a factor. But you know, you go to Toronto in July and the Toronto Maple Leafs are on the front cover of the sports pages. You know, that's amazing. Yeah. They're huge. I know. But anyway, how great was he?
他真是个好人。我爱他。我喜欢和他在一起。他是最好的人，我真为他感到高兴。他是个非常聪明的人，即使没有别的，他也确实改变了人们看待多伦多那支球队的方式，而且他……是这样吗？绝对的，伙计。
He's such a great guy. I love him. I love hanging out with him. He's the best dude and I'm just so happy for him. And he's such a smart guy and even if nothing else, he's really changed the way that people look at that team in Toronto and he's... Is that right? Absolutely, man.
他改变了整个文化。他一直对这件事有长远的眼光，而且，你知道，他有这个东西，香农计划，他，你知道，有时人们称赞他，有时他们试图把它挂在他的脖子上。事实是他真的很冷静。他知道他有信心，从长远来看，他们会做得很好。所以是的。嗯，那很有趣，你们。
He's changed the whole culture. He's always had a long view on this and, you know, he has this thing, the Shannon Plan, which he's, you know, sometimes people lot him for it and sometimes they try to hang it around his neck. The truth is he's really calm. He knows he's confident that in the long term, they're going to do well. So yeah. Well, that was fun, you guys.
那真的，真的很有趣。我真的，真的很喜欢。喜欢见到他。喜欢见到他。我希望这种病毒消失，这样我们就能回到洛杉矶，或者我们去那边，我们去吃顿晚餐。那很好。是的。
That really, really was. I really, really liked that. Love meeting him. Love meeting him. I hope this virus goes away so we can get back out here to LA or we go over there and we go get a dinner. That was nice. Yeah.
是的。我也希望你的病毒能好起来，杰森。而且只是，我想湿巾和多睡觉。好的。如果我稍微向下倾斜一点，你会看到它真的在渗出。脚在割伤。脚在割伤。一个渗出的伤口。
Yeah. I hope your virus clears up too, Jason. And just, I think wet wipes and a lot of sleep. Okay. If I just tilt down a little bit, you'll see it's really weeping. The feet's cutting. The feet's cutting. A weeping wound.
好了，伙计们。超级有趣。这是我的小男孩。再见。聪明。加。聪明。加。
All right, guys. Super fun. This is My Little Boy. Bye. Smart. Plus. Smart. Plus.
加。是的。是的。再见。再见。聪明。加。聪明。
Plus. Yeah. Yeah. Bye-bye. Bye. Smart. Plus. Smart.
加。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
另外，本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。